c'est une pause bisous olivier non non
je t'explique la mer quand tu quand tu
arrives sur une terre à la terre c'est
toujours une ombre c'est une ombre qui
ressemblent ces accros qui en fait c'est
jamais une couleur c'est toujours un
dessin c'est toujours ces deux s'est
tout à coup
cet horizon qui est plat il ya une bosse
qui est différente de celle des autres
c'est ça la river cette terre nous vu de
la mer c'est le code de du monde qui
naviguent la plupart des gens qui payent
ma mère il à peine du board dudes est
vrai sur le sur la terre il paye ma mère
et moi je voulais emmener un gars qui
fasse comme les déchets les navigateurs
dans le temps qu'ils fassent le croquis
des atterrages le croquis des approches
qui regardent la terre vue de la mer non
c'est un autre monde fin c'est un métier
très important c'est un métier séculaire
[Musique]
non
non je ne sais pas où tu remets pas ne
fait pas pu dire les gens je t'appelle à
l'oreillette tu ne réponds pas non parce
que tu as à occuper mais je suis en
train de se shooter avec olivier c'était
déjà en ligne avec canal+ faut le dire
un au nom mais ce rêve dit on n'a pas
fini je te signale en vacances encore
arbres non c'est pas vous vous êtes
formidables mais non ça va pas il ya
encore deux émissions à produire mais on
se fait chier la mort
mais là on s'emmerde à c'est tout le
monde son maire d'enrichissement garde
laisse tomber quissac a fait ce plateau
là c'est nul c'est tricoche oui j'ai
passé deux filles sur le plateau on
regarde bien oui heureusement qu'à
hambourg mais sinon c'est trop viril
les gens sont habitués ça c'est bien toi
tu es bien tu fais du bateau toujours du
canot et tout ça non mais c'est
intéressant mais tu peux pas raconter
des blagues de cul plutôt comme un peu
comme à la radio parce que la voile les
gens n'aiment pas je crois
laurent j't'adore avec j'adore c'est
formidable c'est très bien puis mettez
un peu dit qu'est ce tu vas qu'est ce
qui va faire à la rentrée se passe
le pauvre jeu c'est une des gouttes
tabouret qui sait qu'elle fait ce décor
dit tu es payé à la main tu le fais sans
leur la vanne lui son retard voilà donc
à 855 m
tout à l'heure il avait une perche là
pour faire une vague goyave le mr oizo
pourquoi t'as pas dit maintien c'est
peut-être delanoë c'est le même de paris
qui a fait drôle
lula va être très belle un face à face
te jure sinon ce crochet pourquoi tu
demande pas des questions de fond à
bernard oui pourquoi tu ne demande pas
combien il a payé le togo pour que la
espérons que oui l'art ou quoi ou non ce
mardi seront ces reliques et oui à temps
battiston et des surtapis enfin le super
sauze non ça dépend des moments
et puis il ya un goon entre les 2 1 mais
non n'est pas aux chandelles qu'il est
con
lui et a du boulot ce top 10 pour la
rentrée h tél bon tu te démerdes l'effet
que c'est qu'on se bouge la place de
gomis est simple
j'ai rarement vu ses crédits à ses pairs
c'est à quelle limite catherine barma
c'est l'incarnation catherine barma ce
qui n'est pas notre plan pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux